with all the stresses of modern life it
is so important to set aside some time
to get together with your man friends
and relax when you're not closing a deal
or making a baby have yourself a guys
night out just a couple of dudes
enjoying each other's company without
any distractions a guys night out can be
almost anything from having a few drinks
at dinner too going out to a bar to
seeing a movie drunk the important
things that you find another man and you
do it with them Dave and I do it all the
time or experts at it so we figured we
just show you footage of us doing it
your guys line out doesn't have to be
exactly like this but it should be
almost exactly like this Gabe it is so
great that you can make it thanks for
inviting me it's really nice to just get
away from all the women in my life tell
me about it women are the worst ah hate
women dere is almost ready you want a
drink sure I'd love one how about a shot
I think I can wrangle something up to
guys night you guys night
what careful these plates are hot my
girlfriend always makes me watch movies
about quilts and tampons here's so much
later how many pockets your pants off
for ya what do what it's time for
dessert I hope you say broom as long as
it doesn't involve any women of course I
did clown eating pizza yeah yeah good
good job alright I go
alien eating pizza yeah it's a tie again
a beautiful little girl this your little
girl Henry is this your daughter do you
remember your daughter do you remember
your wife do you know who this is him
that's it know where they are gabri is
still awake it's crazy I thought I was
asleep and I'm awake it was like a dream
but then I was just here hey I can't
ever tell with you makes me crazy
somewhat scape thinking in there I don't
know i just see your ear man you seem
tired I'm falling asleep oh no I like
thought about it too much i psyched
myself out it's blow it all right maybe
I'll try to go back to sleep probably
the flashlight here just easier wake up
so dark I need it
oh boy what a great guys night out feel
so rested so I guess it's back to the
lady with you in on game wish I could
stay here forever
ow